The Joe Rogan experience.
It's that,
that's the problem is that I feel like with the,
with the tasks,
I have a model x now,
so I had the SUV now and fix the ultimate flex.
Tiffany Haddish had one and she had it in the parking lot at the comedy store
and she had it dancing,
really filming it,
kind of go up and down and stuff to the music and she's out in front of the car.
Dad said it hurt and I answered it.
Everybody's dancing and they're filming it.
It was a hilarious moment.
And it's funny cause I,
I found myself,
I feel like this car is ruined me as a person,
right?
Like I'm a typically like pretty humble person,
but like having like a Tesla,
the fact that you could push a button and the car comes to you is like the
biggest,
like it's a douchebag move.
Because honestly we were doing,
we were like getting into our cars,
like peasants for years,
you know.
And one day I was at the gym and I was looking at my car from,
you know,
from,
uh,
you know,
from a distance.
And I was like,
you know what,
I really don't feel like walking all the way to my car today.
How far it was probably like the distance from you to me.
It wasn't even that far.
I was like,
I was like a glass in between us and I was like,
you know what?
Come to Daddy,
come to Daddy.
It pushed the button.
The car is backed out.
Everyone's like,
Whoa,
that car's driving itself.
I was like,
yeah,
that's me.
Push the button,
open the door,
got in.
I just drove off.
Yeah.
When I take it and I put it in auto-drive,
that's when it really freaks me out.
Yeah.
Do you use that often?
Doesn't scare me.
Fun.
Yeah.
It scares me.
It scares me,
but I keep my hands right there.
But it is freaky has tried to kill you yet?
No.
Okay,
let's do this.
It's coming.
Really?
No,
I'm just joking.
Just joking.
No,
it's like I always keep my hand there.
I always keep my hand there,
but um,
I'm always,
um,
well one thing I'm concerned with is that I think I'm lowering my guard.
Yes,
absolutely.
I'm letting the car,
I'll do too much.
When you drive.
Like one of the reasons for road rage is when we're driving around,
we don't know who the fuck's next to us and we're going very fast and requires
like the ability to think really quickly.
So your brain is in a heightened state of awareness and then someone does
something stupid like this fucker you pissed off.
Yeah.
Rage man.
Exactly.
Absolutely.
For the rage comes from.
Um,
but it,
it lightens that almost.
Maybe too much.
Cause I think you do need to be,
well Geez,
it's cut into my lane.
Right.
I think you do need to be at least aware that some shit could happen at any
moment when cars are flying by you going 70 [inaudible] so you don't take your
hands fully off.
You just let the car drive itself.
Really?
Yeah.
I just put my hand on it.
I don't take my hands fully off.
But if you do,
you can only do it for so long.
It'll start to warn that's a complaint.
Like,
Hey,
what's going on here buddy?
But apparently some dudes tried,
they say that didn't work.
I talked to one of those dudes who did that,
that experiment.
Apparently that experiment didn't or whatever.
Yeah,
the orange.
Yeah.
These are that orange.
I think I might work,
man.
I think what does work better is like they said all like a lightweight,
like if you take like a,
like a lightweight and put it on like a rubber band and you hang in,
there was,
you know what's funny,
there was a guy that was selling that you hear about that he was selling like it
looked like a,
uh,
it was like basically go wait.
That went around the steering wheel and it actually,
uh,
had the perfect amount of weight balance and make you think that your hand was
still on the wheel.
People were buying it.
There it is.
And Tessa autoplay buddy.
Hi Buddy.
Yes.
Mag relaunches as a phone mount.
Yeah.
So then so,
so amounts we that right.
He was selling it and it was like 300 bucks and then,
you know,
they were like,
that's illegal.
You can't do that.
You're bypassing like a safety device of the car.
So then what he did was he came back again with a vengeance.
It made it a phone mount.
He's clever.
Yeah.
That's a smart move.
Although I'm not sure I support it.
I don't think I do either.
That's kind of,
that's a little bit much.
I don't think it's ready for that.
Weirds me out.
It weirds me out because the other thing is the other people are,
are not going with auto drive.
So you around,
you're going auto drive and all these other people are just driving.
Yeah.
And I think when everyone's driving together,
you kind of in tune with each other.
All this hassle is trying to go really fast.
Yeah.
Right.
Get the fuck on overtake this guy.
Right?
Yeah.
Let me pass this gate you were aware of when you're just,
when you're auto-driving it's like you're like,
uh,
like,
assist,
right in this moving.
Yeah.
Ecosystem thinking.
Right.
All these people be calculating each other,
but it's probably ultimately like if you talk,
talk to Ilan,
he says it's way safer and then it's the future.
I hundred percent agree with them.
Absolutely.
Obviously hates fun.
Yeah.
Cause what would you do that.